Alright, so let me show you some examples on the real chart. So let's suppose that we are in a downtrend and then we are looking to identify market structure breaks. Okay? We are looking for market structure breaks. Okay? So as you can see, price made a new lower low, lower high, lower low, lower high, lower low, lower high, and then lower low,
high then we made a lower low once again. So now this type of market structure is
considered to be a market structure break okay when price continuously makes
new lower lows and the trend is continuing that is considered to be a market
structure break okay so as you can see right around this level price broke
through it that is considered to be market structure break. Then we pull it back and then
price broke through that previous low low and you can see that this is considered to be market
structure break as well. Now what is market structure shift? So as you can see that we
were continuously making low lows, lower highs, lower lows, lower highs, but then we made
a higher high, higher low and higher high. Now this is considered to be now this break right
around here when price breaks through this level, which is the previous low, we made a
lower, lower, high, lower, lower, high, lower, lower, lower low. And then price reversed
Breaking the previous low of the bearish trend. Now this is considered to be a market structure shift
Very very easy guys. I hope you understood what I thought you guys. So this is considered to be market structure shift
so I
hope this is clear and
And as you can see, the price has continued up for a bit, but then it made another, as
you can see, price made another market structure shift.
So we made a higher high, higher low, higher high.
And then we created this lower low, lower high, and then lower low, lower high, lower
low.
Okay.
So you can see how we identify the markets.
Now this was this move right here.
I'm going to price broke this level.
Then it is considered be a market structure shift.
So I hope this is clear now and I'll see you guys in the next video.